hi and welcome to another gamespot
unboxing this time we have the brand new
xbox series x
now you might have seen that we've done
a bunch of tech tests on it already
but this is a final retail unit so i'm
going to be opening it
up and having a look at what's inside
let's take a quick look at the packaging
pretty standard fare kind of awkward
that it's still got halo on the back
but delays happen obviously all the info
about what is actually
inside the box all right razer blade
time let's
open this up
okay
it's literally gift wrapped like a
present
which is nice hopefully people be
getting these for christmas i suppose
let's look at the accessories first
standard
product and regulatory guide warranty
stuff
not very exciting at all okay we have
an hdmi 2.1 cable and we know it's a 2.1
because it says
ultra high speed on it that is the uh
the designation given
to 2.1 hdmis so if you want to be
playing games
upwards of 4k you need one of these bad
boys
here you've got the power cable probably
saw this go viral on twitter a few
while ago uh it is just a standard ac
power cable
if you're using a power cable for your
xbox one x for example
that should actually work with your
series x we had michael heim test that
out
a couple weeks ago okay new controller
so comes with batteries very useful
although along for the day when they'll
finally just have a rechargeable one and
don't need
double a batteries this is the brand new
controller this is my first
hands-on with it i use the xbox elite
series 2
a lot i've been using the dual sense as
well a lot so i can compare it to that
as well as a dualshock 4
and a standard xbox one controller but
first impressions
is that it feels very light they have
these kind of like the texturized
uh plastic on the grips and now on the
triggers which just i mean like it's
still a great controller
a little too light for my taste i like
the fact that the elite is much heavier
i mean face buttons just feel like an
xbox controller
they have redesigned the d-pad but yeah
it feels nice feels more in line with
how i like it on the elite
uh brand new button uh you have a share
a designated share button now so no
longer
is the view button a weird kind of
mashup of a button
now you have a dedicated share button
which is useful for sharing screenshots
and gameplay but other than that it's
like a standard standard xbox controller
it feels nice in the hand but i still
prefer my elite
uh but obviously with the xbox ecosystem
the xbox family
uh all the accessories you had for your
xbox one will work with the new
xbox series s and x and speaking of x
let's open the console time to power my
dreams
good lord it's heavy
that was a legitimate reaction i wasn't
expecting it to be that heavy
merry christmas xbox please put that
clip of usher in
merry christmas xbox it's usher and i
hope that santa got you everything you
asked for including
dan central 3. i'll see you guys in the
new year clearly in quarantine
i haven't been doing any weights um this
is quite heavy
it feels very dense you know it feels
like there's definitely a lot in there
let's go through everything power button
oh that's quite a hard button to press
i don't know if that makes a difference
but if you remember when the original
xbox one came
out the button that was not even really
a button that would turn on
if there was like a waft of air in in
its general direction so it feels
actually quite good to have something
that's quite tactile and gives you
feedback
the disk drive so if you get an xbox
series x
it comes with a disk drive which is very
useful if you buy a lot of games on disk
if you don't then maybe the xbox series
s
is the better option for you but this
drive here and eject
uh disk button button to sync your
controller and a usb
a port we'll move to this side because
this is the side that will be
lying on your desk or table or whatever
it is
you want to put your series x if you
want to have it horizontally so you've
got these like rubberized grips here i
assume that the same ones that are on
the bottom
provide a lot of grip it's actually
quite difficult to move it okay move
around the back of the console now
two more usb uh ports same as the one on
the front of the console
here's where you're gonna put your
ethernet cable if you wanna have it
wired into the internet
here's where your power adapter is gonna
go here is your hdmi out and like i said
it comes with an hdmi 2.1 cable
and also here you have the storage
expansion slot
so storage expansion on the series x
works slightly differently
you can buy an official storage
expansion card which currently runs at
about 220
which is obviously quite a lot of money
for extra storage if you're going to be
downloading loads and loads of games
you don't think that the one terabyte
internal storage is going to be enough
there are options for you there are the
official storage
uh card like i mentioned but if you want
to go on gamesup.com michael has done a
rundown of
testing external hard drives just usb
hard drives and kind of weighing up the
load times
of games that are on external hard
drives compared to using the internal
storage
so go check that out if that's going to
be a big issue or a big selling point
for you
and then on this side just plain
plain side it's got my grubby
fingerprints all over it now let's take
a look
at the bottom so the bottom is actually
just all one of these
big rubberized grips no wonder she
wasn't moving when i was trying to pick
her up and move her about
but let's look at the top oh god
and so the top is where you'll get that
splash of color that xbox green
uh in the vents in the top here i
remember the first time at the game
awards when we got that look
uh the first ever look at the series x
and everyone was just talking about
how monolithic it seemed and how huge
and honestly
considering the power that you've got
inside this thing this is smaller than
it should be
honestly like now seeing it in the flesh
i can totally see where it's gonna live
in my house
you know it just it just seems to fit in
i'm actually kind of surprised at how
small it is
this is a decently sized console and
then the final thing in the box
uh you've got a little getting started
quick start guide
which could also double as something to
hang on your door if you don't want to
be disturbed because you're gaming too
hard
that's a joke it doesn't actually say
that just tells you to go download the
xbox app and use quickstart to get it
all set up and running
so that was the unboxing of the xbox
series x
obviously for more on the brand new
console as well as the series s
and playstation 5 keep your eyes peeled
to gamespot
[Music]
you